as the temperatures warm up out there
one woman is making sure infants and
children are comfortable in the water
with life-saving skills to prevent
drowning her work has inspired many
families including one who knows
firsthand how quickly a tragedy can
occur victoria saha joins us with a look
at how crucial it is to start infant
swimming resource lessons victoria sasha
here in las vegas many homes have pools
which means the dangers of the water
linger on all year long but infants and
small children may not know just how
dangerous it can be which is why it's so
important to teach them how to save
themselves if they go under
many parents think swim lessons are all
a child could ever need to save
themselves in the water we're not going
to teach them how to blow bubbles we're
going to teach them how to hold their
breath but infant swimming resource
lessons also known as isr instructor
jessica tuck says this is a crucial step
that needs to be taken first any kiddo
that could crawl could reach the water
unattended kids are curious they're
competent good job
tucker teaches children how to save
themselves with breathing exercises and
instant reflexes like rolling onto your
back to float up
life-saving scale sierra mendoza says
she wishes she knew of when her son died
after he was pulled from a home pool
during a family gathering by the time we
were ready to leave
he was nowhere to be found an adult had
taken her 17 month old son austin by the
backyard pool
as the adults got distracted austin
stepped onto the pool cover and fell in
and they found him probably about
four feet in
the water just
lifeless austin survived but had severe
neurological damage at only 10 years old
he passed away they have no idea how to
save themselves so they take a breath
and immediately they aspirate mendoza
says it was hard for her to go near a
pool again but eventually learned about
isr she had her youngest go through the
program and is now getting certified to
help other families drowning time
doesn't happen during swimming time and
so we
in isr are setting our kids up for
success we want them to experience
falling into the pool
mendoza has one more week to finish for
her certification and on may 16 she'll
be conducting her first lesson exactly
eight years since austin died if you are
looking to get an instructor for your
child make sure they're certified we
will have more information up on our
website at eight newsnow dot com sasha